bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur votre
chaîne de vulgarisation politique
la chaîne qui vous expliquent nos
institutions françaises aujourd'hui on
va parler des ordonnances si vous suivez
notre chaîne vous connaissez déjà
peut-être la constitution les lois et
les décrets qui en font partie de la
famille des textes réglementaires donc
inférieur aux lois en termes de
hiérarchie si vous nous suivez sur
facebook ou sur twitter vous avez
peut-être vu nos infographies sur les
ordonnances donc vous les connaissez
déjà peut être un peu mais comme elle
est très gentil avec vous en plus des
infographies on voulait explique aussi
en vidéo
comme l'a dit dans les précédentes
vidéos dans l'ensemble des normes
françaises il y a d'un côté les lois qui
sont définies dans l'article 34 de la
constitution et qui s'appliquent aux
domaines très importants comme les
libertés publiques les droits syndicaux
les libertés religieuses
enfin tous les domaines importants qui
régissent le pays
les lois sont prises par le parlement
mais pour des domaines un peu moins
important ou plus précis où une bande en
face sur l'ensemble du territoire
il y a les règlements qui eux sont
décrits dans l'article 37 de la
constitution et qui sont pris par le
président de la république le
gouvernement ou encore l'administration
dans la famille des règlements ils y
allaient des frais les circulaires et
les arrêter et entre les deux on
retrouve les ordonnances qui elles sont
décrites dans l'article 38 et dans
l'article 41 de la constitution et c'est
ce dont on va parler dans cette vidéo
les ordonnances elles sont un peu
particulières
c'est le gouvernement qui demande au
parlement l'autorisation de prendre lui
même les mesures qui relèvent
normalement de la loi pour mettre en
place son programme ou dit autrement
l'ordonnancé la permission donnée par le
parlement à ce que le gouvernement
emprunte de façon temporaire sans
pouvoir législatif donc son pouvoir de
faire les lois et prennent des mesures
qui normalement ne serait pas de son
domaine pour donner au gouvernement
cette autorisation
le parlement vote une loi d'habilitation
c'est le parlement via la loi
d'habilitation qui fixe les délais
pendant lequel le gouvernement a le
droit de gouverner par ordonnances et
surtout les domaines précis dans
lesquelles il peut le faire dans le
projet de loi le gouvernement doit
indiquer avec précision les buts des
mesures qu'il veut mettre en place et
leur domaine d'intervention
pour donner un exemple si la loi
d'habilitation autorise le gouvernement
à prendre une ordonnance concernant le
code de l'environnement
celui ci ne va pas pouvoir modifier le
code de la santé publique
l'autorisation prise par le parlement
s'appelle habilitation législative
l'ordonance elle est rédigée en conseil
des ministres sous contrôle du conseil
d'état elle va ensuite être signée par
le président de la république
l'ordonnancé entre en vigueur dès sa
publication en tant que texte
réglementaire c'est à dire en tant que
tu être inférieur à une main
le gouvernement peut alors déposer un
projet de loi de ratification au
parlement
la ratification d'un texte en fait c'est
tout simplement sa signature qui permet
d' acte et le fait que le texte est
accepté le projet de loi doit être
déposé avant la fin du délai fixé par la
loi d'habilitation
si ce délai est expiré l'ordonance
devient caduque
donc elle n'est plus valable le
parlement va alors votez pour accepter
modifiés ont refusé le texte proposé par
le gouvernement
si le texte est accepté il va faire
office de loi s'il est refusé et bien
son statut réglementaire c'est à dire
inférieure à une main bon ok mais
pourquoi utiliser la procédure des
ordonnances au lieu de la procédure
ordinaire
en fait il peut y avoir plusieurs
raisons elles peuvent être utilisées
pour traduire et adapté en droit
français les directives de l'union
européenne ce qui a été le cas de
nombreuses ordonnances ces dernières
années mais aussi pour des sujets très
techniques ou délicat dans les cas où le
gouvernement a besoin que les mesures
soient prises rapidement pour pouvoir
exécuter son programme
parce que si vous vous rappelez bien une
loin avant d'être voté doit passer par
la navette parlementaire c'est-à-dire
qu'elle doit passer par deux lecture à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
et ça peut être très long car lors de
chaque passage
le texte est discuté et éventuellement
modifié
l'intérêt énorme que l' ordonnance
apporte par rapport à la procédure
normale c'est le fait que le texte
prennent effet immédiatement et même
s'il faut attendre avant qu'elle
devienne vraiment loin les mesures
contenues dans l' ordonnance sont
applicables tout de suite mais l'
avantage par rapport au décret c'est que
les mesures qui sont présentes dans l'
ordonnance sont normalement du domaine
de la loi
donc ne peuvent normalement être prise
que par le parlement l'ordonnancé donc
une exception donné par le parlement au
gouvernement
donc voilà c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
que c'est une ordonnée
à ce stade de l'explication vous avez
peut-être l'impression qu'une ordonnance
ça ressemble un peu à l'article 49 3 et
c'est vrai que c'est facile de faire la
comparaison
mais comme c'est un point important on
développera dans la prochaine vidéo qui
sera d'aider à la différence entre les
deux procédures pour que ce soit bien
clair si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air
et s'il ya des sujets qui vous
intéressent particulièrement
n'hésitez pas à commenter en dessous nos
vidéos on essaiera d'y répondre
également à partir du mois de juillet on
va commencer à monétiser nos vidéos via
youtube et même si ce sera une somme peu
importante
on aimerait donner l'argent de la
recette à des associations on va donc
mettre un système de votes sur notre
site internet qui sera bientôt en ligne
pour que vous puissiez choisir vous même
à qui vous voulez qu'on donne cet argent
reçu par youtube et bien sûr dès que le
dispositif sera en place on vous mettra
le lien dans la description
sinon n'hésitez pas à nous suivre sur
nos différents réseaux sociaux
on met en place plein de moyens
différents pour vous aider à mieux
comprendre la politique
sur ce bonne journée et à bientôt
[Musique]